Good morning John!
Thanks for the update on America's healthcare situation.
Something tells me that this isn't going to be the last video where you talk about that.
For people who aren't in America,
sorry it's a really big deal for us right
now.
Sometimes I'm really surprised by what people of the world wanna see and,
of course, sometimes you wanna see silly videos,
sometimes you wanna see complicated videos
where we explain things
and one of the things that really surprised me: when we did the Nerdfighter survey
a huge majority of people said that
they wished I would spend more time
writing and producing and releasing songs.
So this is really dumb, this is like textbook example my brain being broken.
When I release a Vlogbrothers video I look at the number of likes and dislikes that the video gets.
Average, we get about 12,000 likes and about 100 dislikes.
When I put up a song, and this is going to sound really dumb,
the number of dislikes will be like double the usual.
That's still only 200 people of 200,000 people disliking the video.
But because it's more than usual, my
brain says
that's not as good as the normal video
so stop doing those.
For so long I pushed making new music to the back burner because I felt like it wasn't as
successful as the other kinds of videos we made.
So yeah, after I got the survey results that lots of people wanted me to make more music,
I started making more music.
For example, I just wrote a song called 'Undigested Lump',
which is about being super angry at
someone and insulting them using only
Shakespearean insults and I'm going to
play it for you right now.
Well I got lot of things I'd like
to say to you
and also just a few I like to actually
do but I don't wanna go to jail and
sometimes my words fail and I don't want to let the worst parts in me prevail.
Saying what's on my mind for me has
always been hard so I'm just gonna leave
this to the words of the Bard: Get out of my sight! Thou dost infect my eyes.
Wilt thou be made a man out of my vice?
O braggart vile and damned furious wight!
Thy tongue outvenoms all the worms of Nile.
Oh hell must be empty 'cause the devil is here.
I've been memorising Shakespeare for nine years.
So I was ready for this.
After what you did, you'll be lucky if
you leave here and you still exist.
You never knew when to shut it.
You carcass fit for hounds.
It's the emptiest vessel that makes the loudest sounds.
Get out of my sight! Thou dost infect my eyes.
Wilt thou be made a man out of my vice?
O braggart vile and damned furious wight!
Thy tongue outvenoms all the worms of Nile.
Injurious, tedious, you bought yourself prentice.
Remorseless, trecherous, lecherous stock fish.
Thou one-trunk-inheriting slave.
You are not worth another word, or else I'd call you, I'd call you a knave.
So you might notice that was a little short, I cut one of the verses off cause it's got a little bit dirty.
Also, this video wouldn't have fit into a four minute video if I had left the verse on.
So... Vlogbrothers rules. I'll be working on an album in November and October.
A bunch of my favourite YouTube musicians are gonna be helping me.
Also probably some of my favourite wizard rock musicians.
It's gonna be maybe a different level from my other albums.
Not to say that my other albums aren't great. I'm pointing at them. They're right over there on that shelf.
I wanted to a be a little more musically cohesive, energetic, but not so weirdly genre isolated with
like, punk rock next to polka. Not that there's anything wrong with that.
Instead, I wanna like, mash and like, have some flow so it's punk rock polka instead of punk rock, polka.
God, now I have to put a punk rock polka song on that album. Oh well.
Nerdfighteria, thank you for supporting me and something in something that I really love doing.
I'm sorry that I was being dumb about it, and yay! Now more music! I punched my microphone. Calm down son.
So yeah, thank you. And John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
The shirt says 'Millipedes are like 10 times better than centipedes'.
Every time I wear this shirt, people in the comments: 'What are millipedes like, Hank?'
It's a threadless shirt, I'll put a link in the description. Also 'cause I kind of feel like I'm getting back in the game,
I just put my two studio albums up as a bundle on DFTBA.com for 15 dollars, which is a screamin' deal.
So if your're interested in getting my music, it is available.